for the European Union and its member
states it is essential to turn our
political support to this peace process
that we have had since the very
beginning of it into a concrete support
to the implementation of the peace
agreements so the trust fund will allow
the European Union and the member states
to accompany projects first of all
focusing on the rural areas for the
concrete peace dividends to reach the
people starting from women and children
and making sure that reconciliation and
peace brings positive results for the
everyday life of each and every
Colombian este fondo es un fondo canal
Babel métier convertir y SI deseo es a
safeway no en una realidad porque ya con
Lori cursos podemos comenzar Edale
beneficios concrete owes a la gente
estamos en un gran momento de nuestras
relaciones entre dan una hora grow pea y
colombia venimos record en un camino
hacia el progreso yeah sarah paz y la
europea tiene confianza en ese camino la
tenido y no saben e dopo y ando en todos
en Tito